gary hired a scotch master to come to
his house and do a scotch tasting
get out of here okay hold on a second
that trophy
hired hired is a funny word um we went
to a charity auction
and we bought it for charity so i
wouldn't say i hired a guy but yes i
paid
i it was it was uh for charity
scotchmaster
is his name scotch master they used to
they used to call those guys alcoholics
now they're scotchmasters
the guy comes in a kilt and then puts
out a bunch of
single malts and he kind of really
listen it's a it's a
it's a lame excuse for drinking i'm not
gonna lie but it kind of teaches you
what's good what's bad how they make it
how it gets the color and all that stuff
and then you know you just keep drinking
it by the end
you're so [ __ ] up so like one of
robin's wine tasting you know give it a
smell
you know give it a sip okay now
everybody take a drink of water because
we're going to cleanse our palate to go
to the next one
and they just you know explain the
different the different variations
the different variations yep so
sometimes
i put my fungus toe in one of the
scotches to see if my toe knows the
difference
oh scotch master scotch master please
scotch talk with gary delabotta anybody
want to hear this yeah
interesting yeah this is it gets deep
man welcome to scotch talk with today's
guest
scotch enthusiast gary delabate i drink
them
as i like them and i am one of those
people
you know i i have the big ice cubes the
big square ones i don't like them
i like it to get a little watered down
just a tiny bit
what i am doing is i'm gonna give it a
minute or two let's just check because i
do like it to get cold
so you can see it's it's the ice is
already getting a little melted so
ready to take a step gary what does the
scotch smell like smells like scotch
yes like scotch it's very good and
what does it taste like it's like a hint
of sweetness but it's not super sweet
i've had much sweeter
ones but there is like a kind of a
little bit of a sweet taste to it
gary do you drink scotch alone or
socially
there's a couple of friends i have that
are scotch drinkers like me that have
big collections
we're big scotch peas by the way i also
have a shrimp master and a plantain
master